sup guys wait a minute
you guys aren't the real Avengers I can
tell Hulk gives it away
Oh
[Music]
Plissken new top no you seen that before
nothing with that skirt you should
probably stop staring with Laurie it's
creepy though too late guys are losers
so to become an Avenger other like
trials or any move you just don't do
anything I would do and definitely don't
do anything I wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate oh all right
that's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
top for you all right kid
good luck out there listen I know school
sucks
Peter you still with us uh yeah yeah I
know you want to save the world
you're not ready you're the spider-man
no I'm not I'm not this is just costume
this is for the ceiling stay close to
the ground
and stay out of trouble
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing you
can treat me like a kid all the time but
you are a kid this is my chance to prove
myself
what is going on with you I'm really
sorry I'm so busy I'm slammed don't mess
with me cuz I will kill you and
everybody you blow
you
you